(Music) "You're just dark Magician..."
69, 69, 69, 69!
We're still waiting for Tekashi69, but STILL. We did it, goddammit.
Good job! ("Shing" noise)
So proud. Give yourself a pat on the back right now, doesn't it feel good?
Doesn't it feel good to know that you made a difference? You made the world at least... a percentage better
Nothing changed. Well, whatever! You did something and for that I give you a thumbs up.
("shing" noise)
You get the "thumbs up PewDiePie seal of approval, then into a brofist".
("shing" noise, cut off abruptly to silence)
But,
there's still one more thing.
There's still one more thing left on the table. What do people actually think about things?
That's what I ask myself every day. Oh, yeah, what does "Teens React" think about that?
If I don't get the approval of "Teens React", then what's the point?
So let's just jump into it, everybody, and see what "Teens React" has to say about PewDiePie...
...being...
...uh, subscribed to by people.
Let's jump into it.
GIRL: Kinda gives me anxiety that they're so close!
He's been the number one subscribed for like, so long, it's about time we had someone else.
(Metal Gear Solid alert noise)
(Furious mouth hissing)
I hate you.
(more mouth hissing)
Teens react to "Subscribe to PewDiePie".
MR. BEAST: We don't mess around.
BOY: I saw this video online. Oh my goodness.
MR. BEAST: Grab your phone, go on to YouTube, search PewDiePie, and subscribe to him.
BOY: Ooh, PewDiePie versus T-Series?
GIRL: I heard about this, like, sub race or whatever. They were both trying to get to like 69 million.
We're both trying to get to 69 million. That's... that's... that was the plan (laughs)
That's... that's right. You got it, you got the story right. T-Series is literally shaking, in the mud, in the dirt, going
"Ah, damn it. He got to 69 million before us! Pack up boys. Let's go back to India."
"There's no reason to keep uploading. He already got it."
That's right everybody, we already got it. Damn, it feels good to be on top.
GIRL: Okay... that's one way to do ads.
That's the best way to do ads.
We don't want none of those stupid "women" to subscribe.
(record scratch) I don't know why I said that... (laughs)
'Cause women aren't real, everyone knows this. Wake up!
GIRL: T-Series, never heard of them.
Never heard of T-Series.
FELIX: Good, good. Keep it that way, if you know what's good for you.
(gunshot noises)
MR. BEAST: T-Series is growing four times faster than PewDiePie.
GIRL: That kinda gives me anxiety, that they're so close!
Not anymore, they're not. I'm miles ahead. (pfft) I could go to sleep. Forever. I'd still win.
MR. BEAST: [If] I don't do anything, PewDiePie won't be the number one most-subscribed...
FELIX: What is Canal KondZilla?!
What... what are all these channels? Where are they coming from?
Aw, God, am I gonna... am I gonna be passed by another one now? What is this?
Now, please. 'Kay? Please...
What are you... no!
And he's got the 420! I didn't want to pull this card, but there is only one number that means more than 69.
9/11. Just kidding. That's not funny. It was kind of funny. Half a second it was funny,
and then it stopped being funny and I acknowledge that. It's not funny anymore.
GIRL: But hey, he's been the number one subscribed for like, so long, it's about time we have someone else.
How could you say that?
MR. BEAST: Therefore, I spent all my money on ads so he can remain the number one most-subscribed-to channel in the world.
Absolute mad lad. What a legend. Never been so proud. This guy's the ultimate homie. He's helping him out
I'm not hating on anybody that is like pure dedication, but I would not do that.
Well I hate on you for saying that how about that?
Take some responsibility and do your part!
So funny like
Every one of his videos is original, is that a diss to me? What do you mean every one of mr
Beast's video I have original To-. Okay fine maybe i dont. Maybe that's why we go so great together, me and Mr. Beast.
perfect match we complete each other. I have absolutely nothing of value and then we have creative original ideas bam!
We should create a channel together maybe a record company. Hmm so we can beat t-series at their own game
Calling all bro's You can save YouTube. Oh my god
Unsubscribe from t-series truer words have never been spoken.
Wonder how many people saw the ad driving home from work?
You see the billboard and you're like I need to pull over right now
I need to subscribe to Pewdiepie right now that person in that red car right there
They just have to stare at Pewdiepies face like the entire time
This is so funny what the hell. This is so distracting on the road.
Lucky Fan whoever is driving that Honda I envy you
Are you subscribed to PewDiePie? No
Can you subscribe to him, please?
Thank you. every little bit counts. See this guy gets the idea
If we work together, well, we already did it. It doesn't matter. Okay. I haven't ever seen an ad at a urinal before
Millions of people every year are affected by awkward handshake that?
that was awful  Thank You conan, he met Conan? that was awful.
How much money did this cost honestly like?
Getting all these ads. Are you subscribed to PewDiePie? Alright? No, where were you?
When this happened, oh my gosh, I need you to subscribe to here Chris
Not sure the viewers can see it alright hit subscribe
Thank you, here you go, here's some
Subscribe to pewdiepie everybody free ketchup. but we do have is original content
I want to go subscribe to help him out
The most accurate news source this planet has.that would definitely get me to subscribe if I wasn't already
67 million subscribers in a night. He crossed many bridges to get where he is today
Oh my god Really you really really you gotta do me like that. can't believe someone would do this. Leave a like if you are depressed watch
what? Pewdiepies fans have been thanking mr
Beast as well as trying to do their part to keep PewDiePie number 1 and so we have some memes
Around that to show you now awesome. Okay. Looking forward to subscribe to PewDiePie
Oh my god
Like that's the first thing that pops up. Google: I'm doing my part. so that's so it's so random like this is so dope
That's cute. That's cute. Even Google knows what's up? Mr. Beast's impact
Plus 85462 subscribers. Yeah, it's even more now. It's pretty crazy
It's like this thing is even bigger than I am no. Wait that, that's not possible
low key I'm part of the nine year old army actually highkey. What am I talking about subscribe to Pewdiepie fine? There you go. There you go
He understood finally he was like, oh god, I got to do my part. There you go
Well done a lot of small ad space in my local newspaper and published this I did my part pewds. Help pewds be the first
One to reach 69 million subscribers in the newspapers and we get the old people to subscribe to him still newspapers people
Do you know about that this are so thing. I want to know how many people clicked on that link
I think you can if you hit a + after two thousand six hundred people
Get two thousand six hundred people clicked
Elon musk. Send me your dankest memes
Pewdiepie meme review when?
Midnight, write subscribe to Pewdiepie on your next rocket launch.
That's the thing that you can't mess around with Elon Musk like that cuz you know, he'll do something like that.
People are really, really involved in this
This is so stupid, like literally so stupid for this many people to care about it.
I'm confused - I'm entertained. That was, that was pretty crazy.
The Internet is reacting how the internet reacts to a lot of things
Just kind of blowing it out just so that way it can have its like moments of fame and get those last little subscribers
No, no
What are you saying are you saying that I'm just getting subs now and then after a month or so no one will care
Were you aware that the most subscribed YouTube channel was possibly about to change?  No, I literally did not know this channel even existed
I didn't even know that was like even happening. I wasn't aware at all. I mean I
I'm, not even subscribed to PewDiePie
Some people are just cruel. "Now, I will." oh okay
Originally socialblade predicted that t-series to pass Pewdiepie in subscriber count' on October 21st of this year
But this gap began to slow down and is now estimated that they will  pass by November 14th, right? There's still winning. What?
No, I I pad I thought they gave up
fine
It seems that we got the teens on our side, but let's see what the youtubers are saying
The youtubers react. when you see how like t-series is taken off. It's shocking that PewDiePie has so many subscribers
Ok try guys
Why don't you try and leave good one?
So the channel is called t-series. He's heard of t-series. I haven't. It's not really a fair comparison
One guy and you know editors and what not vs. Massive corporation with thousands of employees
It's different. There should be like different
Buckets on YouTube one for like the youtubers and the other for like this is a big company. God Damn it Jordan
Well said level 10 book
Excellent. Good take the only good take I've seen in this video. T-series vs. PewDiePie. I mean Pewdiepie is very very YouTube, right?
It's man speaking at camera. Honestly when you see how like t-series has taken off
It's shocking that PewDiePie has so many subscribers. I don't like how they laugh like that
Ok, dont laugh at me like that
They mostly post bollywood music soundtracks and film trailers, t-series is also the world's most viewed YouTube channel with over
47 billion views. That high? Oh my god
And they're gaining almost a hundred thousand subscribers a day hundred thousand new subscribers every single day. Oh my god. I
Got to get onto this T-series. What do you think
about them that could make them potentially the number one channel of all time
Is that the only place to go to for that type of content?
That's right congratulations you got monopoly
Do you know how many scruffy-looking awkward boomers ranting about different topics into a microphone and a camera?
There are on youtube
Do you understand how tough it is in this market to do what I'm doing?
So many have made the argument that it isn't fair to compare
The two channels since t-series is a full-fledged Network and company that uploads multiple videos per day created by many different artists vs
PewDiePie who is an individual creator who developed his following entirely through YouTube. Yeah
Well, I mean, I good good for PewDiePie cuz you know, he did it for this long. still doing it still doing it!
Thank you. Whenever you go on trending, you always see like like the Jimmy Kimmel show or you just see like the next
Netflix trailer it's it's it's getting to that point where it's gonna be a global market of just different
production companies.
Damn.. damn that's depressing to think about isn't it?
Guess I never thought about it that way. Things are always changing on YouTube. I think that's what makes it interesting
That's what makes it fun. No one saw it coming
but and in such a quick timeframe as well for my 11 years on YouTube I've seen
time and time again the top 5 positions be
Creators on YouTube maybe. I remember it differently, but when I started off there was a bunch of
there was more companies big being big on YouTube, but
Creators kind of took over. I wonder if the same sort of trend will apply to to
India now
and maybe we'll see the actual independent Indian creators the appeal and the value of investing in YouTube content it will
More and more be taken over by companies
Logically thinking it's going to become more and more coperate, corporate
There's just so many giant companies trying to keep up with YouTube and if they want to stay in business, it's almost
Obligated at this point to do something
I know there's you know even creators that are just actors in channels and they don't actually own the channels
I mean just look at Smosh, you know
it came out a few days ago that Smosh actually sold their channel and
They're really just employees for Smosh and all this time. You think it's a private channel
It's it's just another company and I wonder if that applies to other channels
I don't think a lot of people realize that for example, I'm glad I'm independent
At least that's about the only thing I had good thing. I haven't working for me right now
You can't compete with that as an independent, but you you know, you shouldn't be thinking of it as a competition
Anyway, there's plenty of people and views out there for all of us.
NO
I NEED MORE!
I need more subscribers god damn it. Meanwhile PewDiePie 2012 like half a million it's amazing. It's a huge number
You know, I'm really happy about it. But still it's just a number and what really matters to me at least
It's the support that you bros show in all your videos. That's like if that's what really means something
I think you think shut up Felix
Anyway, hope you guys enjoyed this video, you know what to do. That's right. That's what I thought. See you tomorrow